because this conference is very important
we already have 42 years of having a
national presence
strengthening small
latin and latino businesses and to come to las vegas' for
the first time to work with the
hispanic chamber here the latin chamber very
strong with the site peter guzmán is  It is a
great pride for us to be here to
have a presence in
a state that is growing rapidly,
not only in terms of the Latino population,
but economically, so for
us being here is a
positive message that we believe in the future of
this state, but knowing  also
that we give them a national presence that
there are also Latinos here, not the most in
Texas, about Florida, in California,
but also in Nevada, in Heleno, in
New York, Montana, Colorado, in these
states,
states of the future in the population of
Latinos and Nevada is  growing
rapidly growth here is the
fastest growing
Latino community in all of the United States
[Music]